bonjour et bienvenue sur des modèles tv
pour ce championnat du monde 2016
cinquième partie du match les deux
joueurs sont à égalité magnus car cette
pièce blanche face à sergei k yaguine
pièce noire que va faire car scène que
va faire car la chine ayant alors tout
de suite avec les premiers coups car
scène débute par le cat voilà donc il
insiste un toujours sur ce début du pion
roi qui va dévier le premier des parties
précédentes ou 5 encore la réponse
symétrique carrière trois câbles et c6
voilà donc est-ce que carsen va insister
food et 5 la grande espagnol la rue
lopez la fameuse du moins espagnol qui
sortit son son livre théorique très
important en 1561 pour décrire pour la
première fois ce début viens on va le
voir tout de suite avec le coup de coeur
scène qui suit il choisit et non voilà
fou c4as c'est la première surprise est
la partie donc carsen choisi de jouer à
l'italienne ça c'est plutôt le coup
l'italien est pas le coup espagnole où
ces quatre coups classiques coûts
importants et très popularisé par les
italiens notamment grieco et puis
ensuite bien repris pendant très
longtemps
ce coût a dû beaucoup devenait même
bobby fischer jouer à jouer vous c4
kasparov a joué tous ses quatre y
compris un championnat du monde avec le
fameux cambier 26 à ce qu'on va voir ce
qu'ils confèrent les noirs ou c'est
celle qui l'a pas peur car allait finir
en train dans la variante la plus aiguë
certainement il est aussi le coup
cavaliers m6 sur vous c'est 4 qui promet
aussi de belles empoignades
alors sous ses seins qu'on peut jouer
beaucoup de choses et notamment le
fameux gambie evans c'est à dire qu'on
joue le pion ici de deux cases et quand
les noirs prennent tous ces trois avec
l'idée de jouer des cas très vite et de
faire aussi le rock
avec une partie très puissante
tactiquement alors que va faire car
c'est ce qu'il a choisi de jouer sur
cette ouverture est donc c'est le petit
remplacer le c'est plutôt tranquille
enfin tranquille entre guillemets la
joke au canon il veut très certainement
joué des coups comme des trois c 3po 1
ce qui ramène finalement souvent dans
des schémas espagnol parce que le fou
vienne traces eux se caler parfois s'il
a joué 6 3 il pourrait faire foule est
très fier d'eux où il revient aussi en
effet ben on va voir ce qui s'est passé
kapsys par carla qu'il est normal le
coup à la fois logique rapide puisque on
prépare le rock c'est très bon détroit
il fallait bien défendre et si le tuant
quatre cavalières appui solide de le
faire mais c'est pas la plus rapide pour
jeu des cadres bien sûr peut aussi
tenter pour eux un os et de jouer ces
trois des quatre mais s'il est l'ours
mais évidemment ne sont pas sans
ressource d'être petit rock maintenant à
4,70 s'intéressant à 4 il veut prendre
de l'espace un petit peu elle d'annecy
carcelle avant d'envisager de faire des
choses des six pour les noirs coup très
logique très solide des six je protège 5
je prépare la sortie du fou angers 4 où
je mets la pression sur ce cavalier donc
ça va affaiblir la caisse des 4
évidemment puisque ce cavalier protège
donc les blocs peuvent l'empêcher par h3
ou autre chose alors que fait car celle
et bien tous ces trois ans n'est pas
pressé ces trois donc sur cette
manoeuvre là que font les blancs
d'habitude eh bien on met le cavaliere
des deux voies la tour e puis le carnet
bien un feu puis on peut jouer h36 le
poussant match 5 qu'on joue qu'avec ses
trois attaquants le fou peut même jouer
qu'à y aller j'ai 3 avant de jouer les 3
voilà et c'est finalement le fou doit se
décider à prendre quand même alors qu'on
n'a pas à jouer des quatre au centre
et qu'on a remplacé le contrôle de d4
ici par les cavaliers ont remplacé par
l'action ces trois ans alors c'est les
manoeuvres le classique
donc voilà car si el qaria qui ne se
pressent pas pour envisager fuji quatre
jours plus tôt à 6 l'idée inversée pour
les noirs de ce qu'on avait vu par kaya
qui n'est quand il joue à trois on met
le four 1 à 2 quand lui-même allé blanc
eh bien il le fait aussi avec les noirs
petites oreilles d'âne là on appelle ça
une oreille dan et quand on fait les
deux bambins lalanne couplet on dit
souvent qu'il faut pas jouer pions sur
les ailes mais évidemment ce principe
général n'est pas tout en bray est ici
c'est bien sûr pour préparer une très
jolie cage pour le fou ans à sète où il
continue d'exercer une très belle
pression sur la grande diagonale tout en
étant improbable ici
alors en plus on joue ainsi c'est bien
on peut anticiper la venue puis d'une
pièce en en b 5
que ce soit le cavalier b 1 à 3 des 5 ou
le fou mais dans ces quatre je pense que
c'est pas très envisageable
l'abbé 4 pour les blancs et blanc eux
prennent de l'espace ne sait rien
forcément décisif bien entendu après
fois c'est à la fois cet aimant une
position très solide c'est très
difficile pour les blancs d'envisager de
faire quoi que ce soit sans s'affaiblir
au même faut donc bien réfléchir avant
de pousser plus de tuyaux en avant tout
un très bon coup bien sûr surprotection
de 4 ans qu'à deux des cinq reprises en
d5 et e5 est en prise de la tour du
cavalier voilà c'est un peu logique et
en plus ça peut envisager maintenant ou
plus tard de jouer des quatre puisque la
tour protège le pion faudra aussi faire
attention autour des 4
pour qui les emprises du cavalier c6
voilà mais c'est l'idée
cette regroupement des pièces pourquoi
pas donc il veut pas mettre son fourrage
et 4 ne veut pas donner assez fou contre
cavaliers pour donner la paire de fois
l'adversaire il joue plutôt cavalière
celle qui veut replacer ces pièces
peut-être fait très certainement pour
venir
angers 6 s'est jamais mauvais dans ce
type de position d'un objet six qui
visent la cazelle f4 où ils peuvent
venir bien se positionner dans le temple
en étant protégé ça veut dire qu'il faut
le faire tout de suite puisque en cas de
prise du foot bien sûr sahel une région
du centre
or n'y est pas mais c'est vers là que
cette somme se diriger ce cavalier
calais b d2 tout à fait classique quand
il de développement cavaliers voilà qu'à
venir ici ce qui a valu une place et hop
est maintenant d 4d carac au profit du
fait que le cavalier partie angers 6 en
cas de prison pour vous prendre du plomb
et le pont bekkat ne sera pas attaqué on
commence à faire pression sur le centre
noir rejoint des quatre si on bouche
bien sûr la diagonale de ce fou voilà
est à propulsion et deux moteurs est
absurde et 4 voilà les noirs sont bonne
position très solide la entreprises pas
de problème tout soutien le calaisis 6
protège et si les blancs poussent leurs
pions des simples fou ici se retrouve un
petit peu bloqué par son propre pions
bon faudrait faire une être une attaque
une grande attaque de pions pour l'un
des cinq le fou bouge c4 c5 aussi de
casser la structure de pure noir est
ouvert le clown c'est un plan à long
terme
à noter que là encore dans ce type de
partie decaux piano ou espagnol
on voit bien d une notion similaire ici
c'est qu'au bout de onze coups n'a
toujours aucune pièce échanges et aux
hommes qui ont échangé toutes les pièces
sont pour la c6
ou logique là encore c'est 6
on libère des possibilités pour la dame
c'est le premier point
bon on contrôle la case des cinq donc on
peut envisager tôt ou tard de jouer des
scènes soi même voilà d'accord le foot
avec une très bonne que le propre
protection de la pièce delà de la case
ces six volets ou tranquille donc les
noirs considèrent que leur fou et encore
sans doute sur sa meilleure case ans et
heureusement de venir échanger contre le
cavalier il pourra se réveiller plus
tard et se développer une fois qu'on
aura décidé de faire des échanges au
centre voilà au moins cinq considère
qu'il est très bien là et finalement
c'est pas la peine de le changer de
place il contrôle bien une grande
diagonale ici intéressant pourquoi
bouger
il ya d'autres ouvertures comme ça au
souffle s'est vite de bouge pas
notamment dans les stades y est du côté
noir
il reste à la maison très longtemps en
fait alors il défend la lhdaa mais il a
un oeil sur les droits il est très bien
et fiable h3 voilà tout cas c'est fini
pour g4 c'est fini pour f5 c'est pas la
peine hier pions pour aux six banques
font envisager une prise du fou ça
serait pas bon il faut aussi ce fou
prend pions prend au prince 85 et après
la reprise est bien on a des pions de
doubler la serait pas terrible donc que
la bête la regarder c'est pas l'idée des
noirs regard des très jolies karekin
très simples pions prend des quatre
voilà et après plus on prend des quatre
îles quasiment forcé va pas laisser
mûrir en c3 nous combien ça ne sent très
bien et là le pseudo sacrifice cavalli
prend le cas très bien vu voilà très
simple ce doux sacrifice sacrifie le
cavalier apparemment mais en fait après
cavale et prend ou paie prend on a mis
une case une pièce pardon sur quatre
dans ce cas là le plus des 5 attaquerez
à la fois le fou et la pièce où l'on
récupère immédiatement le sacrifice
c'est pour ça que c'est pas un vrai
sacrifice
c'est un coup qu'il faut savoir jouer
qu'on retrouve dans beaucoup de
positions c'est en fait un échange
dynamique avec un pseudo sacrifices
auxquels et blanc le choix je peux
prendre le cadre est calculé ce qui se
passe sur des scènes où je peux jouer ce
que fait car celle-ci vous choisi de
faire vos preuves sept ans c'est pas
forcément le meilleur
l'acm et c'est beaucoup voilà c'était
mon coup puisque après 9,7
on récupère bien sur 24 on a préféré
troquer contre le pion à vii alors que
si on avait joué qu'à l'épreuve quatre
des cinq on aurait troqué le pion des
bons alors on affaiblit un peu le roi
noir s'ils sont utilisés de farce l
affaiblissement du rendement war
possibilité pour les blancs de mettre
une cavalière ou g5 soit le cavalier ou
4 ce qu'elle est ce trop mais plutôt le
fait je pense pour les cff 3 ici et si
la tour bouge après un coup comme dame
en b3 échec et ça peut devenir vite
pénible
voilà donc avalé prendre quatre il a
affaibli les charmants nous aurons noir
décisif surtout plus tard scène montre
l'idée aussi c'est que lille joue
lui-même
desseigne donc tu auras pas il aura
jamais de dam des trois échecs bon et on
a bloqué cette diagonale
il faut que les blancs jouent leurs
cavaliers sans doute dans la position la
plus active c'est ce que fait qu arsène
sont notre meilleur qu'à blesser c'est
je pense ce coût est important il faut
mettre le client c'est simple parce que
non seulement on est dans le camp ennemi
on contrôle des cases intéressante on
immobilise ici les pièces les deux sens
du terme vaisselle mais on bouche la
limonade du fou surtout ce fou est
bloquée surjoue b6 aux joutes cavaliers
et le fou c'est bloqué par son propre
pions voilà donc on a rendu ce fou
inoffensif en le bloquant pour un
cavalier tranquille alors à noter qu en
termes de structure quand même les
blancs un petit problème c'est qu'ils
ont un deux trois îlots de pions et puis
on va 2b deux sont liés à pardon à 4 b 4
le terme des quatre est isolé f2 j'ai 2
h 3 du côté droit
trois îlots trois cibles potentielles
mais
beaucoup d espace une case 5 qui leur
temps leurs bras les le bras pardon donc
s'il met cavaliers en scène qu'en cas de
prison va reprendre sans doute du pion
qui va se relier avec ses collègues donc
donc rien finalement de vraiment
important un poste de grands grands
espaces publics agissent maintenant très
jolie du coup de car celle ci lui aussi
l'influencé 1 qui attend un petit peu de
savoir où se placer et finalement il est
pas si mal en c1 déjà puisqu'ils
contrôlent une belle diagonale notamment
lacazette 4 très importante puisqu'il
empêche le caméléon 4 donc il se dit ce
flou et peut être sans doute sur son
meilleur cases comme le fou s'est vite
donc il va après regardez h6 de
khanaqine se dire en plus maintenant bon
les joueurs si c'est sûr c'est important
puisqu'il empêche le relais gsm mais
c'est une cible à 6 pourrait faire
l'objet d'un sacrifice dont certaines
dans certains cas et en inde et le joli
coup car scène donc une fois considérer
que ce fou sur sa meilleure case tour à
3 moi j'adore ce coup on à petit la tour
latéralement
voilà donc on passe par a3 maintenant
qu'on a déblayé un petit peu le passage
a pas de pionnière indigènes on peut
venir en trois et on double les tours
voyez tout de suite on menace déjà toro
huit échecs gagne adam
on n'en est pas là mais voilà cette tour
va s'activer facilement et on laisse le
fou sur sa meilleure case voilà faut pas
sortir les pièces pour le sortir faut
trouver le lan droit où elles sont
placées de manière optimale c'est à dire
où elles ont une activité la plus grande
possible ou un rôle de défense le plus
actif possible ici l'oncfs f5 pour les
noir sans doute la seule case pour ce
fou pour finalement quand même se placer
il veut changer deux à la fois il veut
sans doute changer de diagonale bon
puisqu'il a un oeil ici
mais il ya aussi le fait que
c'est de votre petit peu le petit aegon
a ici mais bon il reste sur la démo n'a
je pensais pas tellement ça l'idée il a
envie de mettre sa tour à 8 lui-même en
jugement il sort le fou et puis s'il
arrive à être une pierre une case pour
la dame intéressantes par exemple sans
doute en c c est ça a l'air bien l'autre
tour peut venir sont en fuite sont 8 mai
venant par an 8 ya la tournée et réfute
alors dans ce cas là pour augmenter la
pression sur le colonel c'est logique la
carcel réagi tout de suite car il essaie
donc beaucoup ici les noirs presle et
après pions prend 1,5
eh bien ils ont réuni leurs pions
croyait on peut venir maintenant joindre
le pion en scène par f4 avec un pion pas
ses protégés mais les noirs aussi hommes
qui ont passé protéger en desseigne
l'assomption est protégé par sa chaîne
de pions ici par ces six qui lui même
protégé par des sets et c'est un pur
passé ils peuvent eux s'avancer est bon
il pas soutenu par le fou à s'être déjà
puisque évidemment le cas des bouges et
puis si la main s'il est plus lié aux
autres pure faire attention à ça fasse
pareil pour les enseignes si on pousse
trop qu'on ait publié il faut quand même
bien calculé qu'on arrive à tenir le
pion et compass le faire croquer un joli
coup noir maintenant d'avast 4 attention
à ce genre de coup quand nous est en
partie damas quatre un petit coup
devenait alors attention ici f2 est
attaqué donc un coup comme fou france 3
pourraient être envisagées sacrifices et
puis ensuite on prend en f2 il faut
calculer ce qui se passe annie et mais
l'autre problème aussi qu'il faut voir
c'est évidemment la fameuse action
latéral
souvent on le voit pas ça la dame en h4
aussi attaque le pion de b4 ya pas que
le pion et vidéos donc il faut la ici
bien réfléchir avec les blancs au
prochain coup il faut faire attention
donc à les blancs jouent tous rêvent
trois jolis coups
punchy parce que ici donc la tour vienne
défendre f2 mais un problème quand même
ces cultures b4 et reprise donc il
fallait calculer cas vu car scène il
faut voir up admettant dame prend b4
dans ce cas là les blancs ont beaucoup
de possibilités notamment le simple ici
fou à 3 on sort le fou on commence à
contrôler la case de 7
ça veut dire que ie6 et la tour pourra
pas venir cette parce que ce cabinet se
ferra qui bouge pour que soient attaqués
donc de 6,7 très vite on va créer des
gros problème côté côté du côté noir par
exemple ici imaginons une suite possible
damascène qu une talent aux 6es ovale à
tours 6 si la tour vient à eux sept
compères le fou on pourrait venir en
epci ou en fuite survient en fuite sans
doute eu 7 est très fort puisque si la
tour est sur la colonne f pour protéger
le fou eh bien on peut faire dame
donc il semblerait que on n'a pas le
choix il faut jouer forcément tour f6 si
on veut pas perdre du matériel et pour
garder le contrôle sur le fou et éviter
e set qui est très fort mais dans ce
cas-là regarder si le massacre
qu'avaient les premiers sets on peut
dire que la partie est finie
les blancs ont récupéré leurs pions ils
ont un pion aux six extrêmement
dangereux
on avance la dame est attaqué et là
regardez par exemple d'un coup comme
dame b 6
alors à mauvais bonds petite batterie
attention ici sur f2 mais il ya la tour
qui veillent et aucun cas de problème
est ici maintenant hop cavale et des six
essais fini partie est terminée puisque
si maintenant on prend avec la tour en
ainsi son père le fou si on prend avec
le foie aussi son échange les tours
peut-être et sans doute on prend le four
n'a pas peur d'en prendre f2 puisque roy
a h1n1 c'est fini a plus rien le roi
elle essaye fait on a une grosse pièce
de plus hélas le cavaliere des six
pourquoi c'est important parce qu'ils
contrôlent la quasi 8
voilà ce qui fait que eux 7,8 et on peut
pas l'empêcher
c'est fini voilà donc d'attention et
surtout après froid il est très
dangereux fin des perdants
et prendre b4 cause tout simplement fou
à 3 qui vient protéger de cavaliers
attaqué la dame et en même temps avoir
un oeil sur la case e7 qui permet à ceux
pions d'avancé
voilà donc évidemment de carrière qu'ils
ne tombent pas dans ce piège grossier
il élimine qu'avait laissé scène c'est
bien c'est propre
voyez comme ce fou était dominée par le
cavalier ce qu'on avait dit on et le
boucher donc la paire de fou ce n'est
pas vraiment un avantage n'est même pas
parlé d'ailleurs puisque les fous
étaient muselés et après le four en
cavalier simplement petit on prend et
s'est terminé alors en termes de
structure par contre l'énorme avantage
puisque là on a quand même endroit trois
îlots à 4 ces scènes sont des pions
isolé alors que du côté noir voyez vous
avez deux îlots des pions donc il ya
moins de cible en termes de pions ceci
dit le pion aux scènes qui est menaçant
à noter aussi que on a une
caractéristique très important nous
c'est une position les fous de couleurs
opposées ici en cas de finale ce sera
très difficile de gagner même si on a un
pion voire même deux pions de plus avec
les pions les footballeurs ont pesé
comme ça c'est très souvent à pas dire
tout le temps facteur 2 nuls
mais par contre un petit reste des
pièces lourdes comme ici c'est un
facteur d'attac voilà parce que
l'adversaire ne peut pas protéger les
cases de la couleur du fond adverse avec
son propre fou donc les deux ont des
motifs d'attac sur les cases de force de
leurs fous aux cases blanches pour les
noirs et ses visées les cannes blanches
case noire pour les blancs à noter que
par contre comme il ya plus de pions
blancs côté roy pour les blancs eh bien
on peut considérer que le roi noir et
sans doute plus en sécurité que le roi
noir qui n'a que deux pions devant lui
voilà faut tenir compte de tous ces
paramètres
quand on rentre au final mais l'ogre
facteurs annulant quand même avec ce
tome 8 très bien bien sûr fallait
empêcher le cistre certainement on
bloque la case aussi son
s'il n'y a rien à faire peut-être tout
va revenir en suit ensuite on n'a sans
doute pas envie de mettre ainsi c'est un
mauvais bloqueurs en général un fou en
tout cas pas tout de suite sinon il
l'aurait fait immédiatement entouré 8
très bons coups d'attaqué russe
t'as que celle contre la casse de 6 3/4
beaucoup très bien tu as dame dans un
peu lassante ici tu peux t'en aller
dams est pas trop de choix pour karine
qu'initie pas beaucoup de coups d'amd 4
1 dans des cas très bien on sur la dame
sur une case centrale
on protège c'est celle qui était attaqué
et ont le temps tout âge
le 5 une bonne dame bien placé attention
pour les blancs pourraient envisager m
en fou derrière la dame ici et ça
pourrait menacer 1,6 l'idée d'attaquer
ici le plonger cette pas certaines
variantes mais protégé pour l'instant
mais on sait jamais pour fuite
voilà les noirs eux mêmes ici augmentent
leurs pressions sur les polonais doivent
croire en relief trois signaux là que
personne n'a pas forcément grand chose
dans cette position effectivement c'est
très très solide pour les noirs et c'est
difficile d'envisager des attaques ici
folk à trois lacs aux actifs
il n'est pas au 6 mai en quatre très
forte case pour le four protégé par le
pion or que fersen va devoir traiter ça
il le fait de façon élégante et rapide
pour preuve cette attaque d'en prendre
on n'attaque pas vraiment f2 puisqu'on à
la dame alors on a mis la dernière 7 et
la voilà c'est ce qu'il fallait jouer f3
le fou va donc devoir quitter cette case
forte donc il a plus de cases forte où
se placer et regarder comment ici on met
les pions sur la couleur du fou pour
justement restreindre voilà c'est le
terme je cherchais restreint dans le fou
cette affaire lui enlever des cases
voilà donc là on joue contre le fou avec
les pions et ça l'affaiblît rien
puisqu'on vous voyez c'est plonger de
quitter la baraque et il
lui même bien protégés par le roi dans
le temps blanc donc c'est très solide et
donc on empêche ou le food de contrôler
le case blanche dans le temps blanc on
le contre de la même manière que les
pions ici contre le fou voilà contre
l'empêchent de venir en gsm mental donc
c'était difficile d'envisager de faire
des choses puisque ce fou même s'il
vient aussi vite plus tard bombay
protégeant très bien la chaîne de pions
ici donc envisager des ruptures c'est
pas simple donc là il va quand même
essayer car celle mais il n'y a pas
grand chose ici au f5 donc très solide
mais arcas pour le fou faut garder un
oeil sur la case de 6 pour empêcher se
tourner avant c'est très important ne
pas mettre ange et six ou sept qui
permettrait aux six en garde un oeil sur
six c'est primordial et puis on va
ensuite pouvoir venir peut-être ans et 8
protégeant 17 peut-être tout simplement
aussi souci là maintenant on va pouvoir
le mettre en six dont les sites très
difficile de viser juste faire des
choses
courage 2006 les coûts d'amélioration on
avait le roi un petit peu plus vers le
centrage de bon ou de protection de la
casse g3 le roi joue son petit rôle
tranquillou et pas grand chose pour deux
voiliers se découvre ton assez passif un
tour deux s'affairaient pas grande chose
ça laisse le phocéen on peut envisager
tomber deux me vont se protéger dès
qu'on va augmenter la pression fous ces
huit c'est fini on peut rien faire on
sait qu'on peut rien attaquer
sérieusement d'alger 6 les noirs se
repositionnent au 3ème set paraît
amélioration des pièces ici do rev 2
petites manoeuvres de peut-être car
celle pourrait menacer et de pousser ses
pions je sais pas elle pas être facile
quand même d'un bep un tour b de bong et
j'attaque mais voyez qu'on a c'est pour
ça qu'il a joué le petit couteau repcet
carrière on n'attaque pas vraiment 17
bien sûr c est qu à seilh fixe fixe les
piaules à ne plus bouger grâce à ses
deux pions là donc ça c'est 7,7 l dame
est quand même dominé par les deux pions
blancs ici qui les empêche de bouger et
les blancs par contre pourrait envisager
de pousser leurs pions la de ce côté là
il faut calculer comment pas facile
parce que liverpool
mais si on veut réagir mais pour bloquer
mais si on arrive à jouer j'ai 4 et 4 f
celle qu est qu on met en mouvement
cette petite majorité de piau ici là l
avantage pourrait quand même faire jour
vous pourrez y avoir davantage donc il
faut faire attention
wii fit faut que les noirs bloc même là
la poussée de ses pionniers droit on va
voir qui vont y arriver assez facilement
films comme c3 mais il faut être précis
3,8 alors c'est bien la manoeuvre ou six
tailles qui n'a compris que la seule
petite faiblesse qui l'empêcherait de
jouer actifs cbc est donc finalement il
a décidé d'envoyer son roi de ce côté là
pour les protéger ce pion avec sa tour
s'il ya deux pièces qui contrôle bien
pour mon pote acquis qu'avec deux pièces
puisque le fouet sur quasiment ainsi que
de pièces et bien une fois que le roi et
ans et 8 ou en b 8 mai ses huit plus tôt
pour éviter des problèmes
tout y est et on peut envisager avec les
noirs de monter quelque chose ici
pourquoi pas puisque le roi n'est plus
là donc il sera moins faible et
si on arrive à ouvrir les lignes avec le
footballeur en attaquant sur les cases
blanches on pourrait créer des problèmes
dans les moeurs
monter une attaque de minorités voilà
deux pions contre 4 essayer d'affaiblir
l'euro blanc pourquoi pas tombé 4 gsm au
bon moment et ça montre les velléités de
carnitine voilà il joue actifs
ils empêchent tout rêve 4 ça c'était le
premier point qui pouvaient échanger des
pièces
il envisage de mettre ses huit pour bien
protéger son aile son aile dame éloigner
le roi de un petit peu du centre des
opérations et les noirs pour envisager
h5 g4 essayé d'ouvrir le jeu pourquoi
pas assez possible
ça pourrait être dangereux faire
attention avec les blancs aussi parce
que là les noirs c'est eux qui
finalement on t'aime verser l'initiative
ici et les blancs n'ont rien attaquer là
ici on n'en a rien à faire l'idée de
pouvoir pousser les pions du roi ici ccc
mort n'y a pas grand chose à faire ne
pas le faire tomber de quad et huit en
continu est vide et donc tous rêvent de
en bon il car c'est ni sait pas quoi
faire
il attend 3 ses huit carats keane il va
essayer quelque chose dans des quatre
dames les six peu d'espoir quand même ça
qu'on est sérieux mais bon voyez si on
joue par exemple le g3 pour jouer f4 on
s'affaiblit
finalement le nord contre toujours très
bien fcl mon projet mais joue au fc et
en plus se regarder le fou attaque f3 ce
que je 3 et 4 qui on prend lyon prend
ces blancs contre une petite faiblesse
pour lui le roi ils ont isolé leurs
pions la colombie est ouverte ça peu
dangereux le pion aux 3 est attaqué sur
des médecins il faut faire quelque chose
ou sur damas s'est donc si on tente des
choses avec les blancs on s'affaiblit
donc on est un peu obligé d'attendre de
voir ce que l'on fait relayer et noir ou
alors de prendre des mesures scofi
carsen ici va prendre des mesures parce
que là les blanc et noir sinon jouer
hcng cas très bon ça peut être dangereux
il jouait même voilà il juge
ils jouent eux-mêmes g4 ont perdu à
celles qui vont pas bouger et ils
tiennent un huitième on va pas jouer f4
non plus parce que l 5 pourrait devenir
fort impose de g4tv etc et sur gk ce
sera efficace surtout les noirs prennent
et le pion aux 5 es tout seul il est
isolé maintenant il n'y a plus de
collègues m'ont c'est fini façon après
d'ailleurs après g5 surtout après j'ai 4
c'est fini on pourra pas jouer g34 s'est
finie sur 24 on prend s'est isolé ça
s'est terminé à plus de questions vous
cache cinq petites pressions et pourquoi
pas une colonne une attaque sur la
colonne h
on met la tour sur h on prend et on
ouvre le joug qui est noirci les blancs
jouent près s'il n'y a pas de risque
mais bon là ils sont plus obligés
d'attendre d'eux attention car celle du
mont très bien tu as bouger tes piot
mais attention ménard regarde g5 et
emprises et oui donc comment on fait
avec les north qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout
simplement autour g7 ou passifs mais
solide ceci dit löw et l'empêchent par
contre ici les noirs de jouer leur pièce
sur la polo nash sinon on prend le
bouillon de cinq et on libère de nouveau
la possibilité pour les blondes jouer f4
et devenir donc d'aider le pion aux 100
est de créer une petite majorité en
marche de pions majoré de pions marche
quand j'ai trois on s'enlève de la
colonne hcca moi j'ai trois sans l'aide
d'un connard 6 et noir jouent h quatre
échecs des blancs seront hyper content
roigé 2 c'est fini il ya plus
d'ouverture de possibles le roi bien
protégés et si les noirs qui ont des
problèmes sur g5 ont ensuite dont on
aura joué f4 ça sera le curage qui
attristera faible voilà donc les blancs
seraient très bien dont g8
une attente d'un g2 est prise voilà
prises angers 4 la cic leur karine se
dit b maintenant que le roi et venir en
g2 les blogs ne pourront pas opposer
peut-être une pièce sur la polonaise
après h 30 j 4 il ya quand même ici bon
ben colonna schuberth il a estimé que la
rétine que c'était ça pouvait être
intéressant pour lui
ça pourrait aussi être intéressant pour
personne c'est une colonne ouverte un
donc c'est vrai des deux côtés de faire
attention et la voilà il détaille acquis
une brillante très joli à regarder
il a ouvert le feu sur la colonne h et
maintenant barre des 4 alors ça c'est
très joli coup c'est typique que dans ce
type de position
c'est quoi l'idée on se dit c'est pas
tellement s'en moque du pion des quatre
en fait on ne donne pas ce qu'on veut
libérer la cause des saints ouais on
veut venir en dessin et on ne fait
pression sur le plot 9,3 sur le roi noir
donc notamment dès qu'on va jouer dames
6 on menace d'un projet quatre échecs
puisque le fou du renflouage
et puis si le foot en d5 une attaque sur
la colonne âge devient pas intéressante
on pourrait sacrifier g5 les cg50 prise
et est monté une attaque violente sur la
colonnade nos initiatives du côté noir
la surprenant faut dire que j'ai 4 2
carsen pour tenter de contrôler aussi
bon mais si il ya donné un peu les
bâtons pour se faire battre ici bon rien
de décisif mais attention dans prend des
cas pour qu'arsène et la voilà comme un
fou dessin on empêche la dame devenir
notre pain noir
et puis surtout ça y est on un fou qui
est magnifiquement patients décèdent
voilà c'est ça surtout se foutent à la
fois actif en attaque puisqu'il vise f3
derrière le roi roger carr et en temps
il ya là toujours en un oeil sur la case
de 6 dont 10 restreint la possibilité
pour les blancs de pousser ses pions
c'est une super pièce ce fou fou dessert
maintenant aussi ce boom évidemment
l'aval idéal en mer c'est à dire qu'ici
les blancs veulent mettre en avant le
fait que cette diagonale maintenant est
faible voilà ça l'idée en juin six tout
de suite
il n'empêche que les noirs bloc par dame
6 et ensuite pour y jouer je sais pas
torah suite puis dame assise avec une
attaque de maths puisque le pion aux
cinq la dame contre les pages suite à la
scala ici elle en est justement plus la
dame contrôler ces diagonales
donc il devient difficile de jouer
tourache 8 pour attaquer sur le clonage
c'est encore une idée de six ou plus
souvent un piano je paie rien mais
attention aussi c'est que ce fou là
pourra plus tard envisager de venir
alors ce fou pour envisager un terme aux
sports a joué le montrer avec la souris
ce fou pour envisager de venir son f2
soit engins pour venir soit 1 200 g iii
très bas des monal et on comprend très
vite que il suffit ensuite de jouer
dames 5 et cécile mort qui va se faire
mater d'envoyer des deux côtés on n'a
finalement pas hésité à donner un pion
pour augmenter la puissance de feu sur
sur les cases blanches pour les noirs et
sur les cases noires pour les blancs 136
d'entre eux six normales dont on prend
ce qu'ils ont quand même la mesure est
là alors attention hein c'est délicat
mélange d'envisager des coûts comment
alors imaginons tour
tours d2 pas pour les blancs tenté deux
avec l'idée vous j'ai trois pour jouer
ensuite autour des 3 pour protéger et il
faut force de fou g3 et envisager ça
mais attention c'est du noir qui attaque
ici damages 6 et attention il ya plus
qu'à jouer tour h 8 et très vite on a
une attelle donc attention et on peut
pas jouer fuji en face d'eux parce que
fuji un tour à schwyz
on peut pas jouer france 2 c'est fini on
va se prendre un échec extrêmement
délicat en h1 et puis si on joue avec
deux tours à schmitt faisait 3 c'est
pareil à damas cherche écoutes à 9 3
échecs avec pénétration il faut faire
attention donc qu'ici après roy pas prêt
d'en prendre six et bien tout simplement
rage et 3 mètres l'emploi ils attendent
la seule ou d'attentes en même temps on
peut envisager de jouer tout rage de la
dame contre la suite peut-être un peu
changé le quart de tour une fois là bas
on ne peut rien pour une lutte donc ici
dames 7
voilà donc très bon contre nous car
scène voilà qui rend qui rend son coup
il a activé on l'a vu cette nuit ronald
qui rend difficile de venir sur la fuite
maintenant il a besoin je venais sur la
colline âge il a affaibli cette grande
diagonale aussi fait noir donc fausse
attention pourquoi faire n'importe-quoi
entourage 2 c'est logique
maintenant damev cette tension 2007
évidemment la faiblesse voilà donc des
cons on essaie de faire des choses on se
prend une attaque sur le pion faible ici
et là car scène tente un truc
intéressant f4 pas mal f4 il dit mais
j'essaie quand même de tact iv
finalement à tout moment ici les blocs
pour ne prennent pas trop de risques à
ouvrir le jeu comme ça on pourrait se
dire ma tension aussi
il ouvre le jeu le roi va se retrouver
plus faibles et ça va être dur et non
parce qu'à tout moment il peut jouer
tourache 8 avec la dame ici donc mais
aussi une paire de tours s'échange
laurent noire elle suffisamment faible
pour se dire bon de toute façon je
risquais rien essayer de gagner pourquoi
pas tenter quelque chose on est un tueur
passé on peut essayer de créer des
menaces m'en f cas donc je bloque la
taxe sur f3 et je peux à tout moment
échangée jour un peu le jeu si les noirs
prennent d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ils vont
faire échec
je peux prendre du fou je peux prendre
de la dame alors ce qui est ce que vous
pensez t'es pas mal aussi il faut
prendre on voit qu il a pris de
l'adversaire mais fou prend c'est bien à
cause donc de cette fameuse diagonale
dont on a parlé le fait qu'on ait poussé
le pion aux cinq ici dans le cinq ici
presque fini la partie finie si les
blancs et si c'était plein de jouets
évidemment c'est au noir donc ici on
peut jouer avec les noirs ainsi un coup
comme dame et f5 très jolie puisqu'on
attaque g4 avec la pour 11,8 battage des
4es en plus et on empêche de 25 en même
temps il faut que les blanc réagit sur
gk de toute façon donc on contre attaque
facilement mais il faut pas jouer deux
coups de deuxième ordre info jouer comme
en écho aux actifs sains ça reste
laurière condition de rester actif donc
qu' on prend f4 les blancs choisissent
de ne pas prendre avec le film avec la
table pourquoi pas c'est bien aussi bien
sûr d'emprunt f4 mais on contrôle plus à
suite par contre payer en un pion passé
avec les blancs là un pion passé il y en
a pas du côté des noirs mais le roi est
très faible et avec le fou est faite que
le reposer on l'a dit d'ailleurs les
attaques peuvent être mortelles
différentes à sion on va faire n'importe
quoi dans le set les blancs les noirs
menace un coup gagnant ici c'était de
jouer sans doute touré fuite et gagne en
attaque attaque ladab et menacent tous
rêvent trois échecs le roi bouger le fou
et a attaqué par la dalle et par la tour
donc il serait perdu mais c'est aux
blancs de jouer chaque fois voilà c'est
une équipe dynamique
ça se joue un temps près il n'y a pas de
problème il faut jouer précis donc si
tout rage c'est très bien joué mais
selon c'est très joli coup en cas de
touré fuite et bien on met la tour
et en cas d' échange on prend du plomb
et le pion avance vers nabeul glv
dangereux donc il faut faire attention
on prend pas de la dame mais sûr puisque
le fou et 3 et en étant prises entourage
saigne très bons coups d' attaque
défense la voilà torres très active
voire même plus actives en corps et en
menace de venir en aide celle qu enfin
on viendra racing complètent le toit
fuit tétouan fuite il le fait quand même
et une autre possibilité que fait car
c'est ni simon tour f500 du très bon
mais surtout f cell
voilà mais yann autre possibilité que
vous personne pourquoi pas bon c'est
plus amusant peut-être je sais pas sans
plus mais voilà tour h7 faut pas avoir
peur et courage c est bon c'est tendu
sicile et noir prennent c'est ce qu'ils
vont faire d'ailleurs on pourrait se
dire ben ouais mais il ya la kf3 en
échec mais il n'y a rien derrière parce
que tout reprend voilà je protège de fou
donc s'amuser entourage 7
on donne une tour là mais en fait sur
d'un prend évidemment c'est d'apprendre
tour échec et c'est les noirs qui ont
des problèmes on sera obligé de sortir
le foot venir en échec mon attention
donc tu orages 7 on va pas prendre de la
dame où il fait des échanges on prend un
tour pendable est ici après le coup
superbe de kayak chine par des c c'est
terminé tour 4 voilà fini fini parce que
là donc on attaque la tour et le four il
faut échanger donc les bhl les joueurs
ici signe là nul et on à la fameuse
finale de fou de couleurs opposées les
blancs ou pas le temps de pousser ceux
qui ont des qui pousse angers c'est
qu'il est bloqué par le flou angers 6 et
le temps d'emmener le roi les noirs ont
le temps d'amener le roi il n'y a pas de
problème c'est très facile à annuler je
vous invite à essayer vous allez voir
que ce qu'on peut pas pousser les pions
puisque les fous que le reposer en paix
il faut que les rois se suivent
par contre il faut faire attention à ça
mais c'est très facile pour ces joueurs
de ce niveau là de savoir que la partie
est vraiment nul et qui a rien à faire
une jolie partie jolie partie djoko
piano de carsen finalement ben tara qui
n'a pas su
non plus profité pour s'activer plus que
ça il ya eu un moment d'initiatives on
l'a vu bon mais rien n'a rien de
vraiment sérieux car tu y en a très bien
joué
il appelle voilà cette ouverture je suis
pas sûr que fersen large où il n'a rien
obtenu dans cette partie on l'a bien vu
et carl icahn a très bien joué il faut
faire tenter autre chose pour parcelles
attention c'était la cinquième partie du
match ça fait cinq parties nulles ça
devient tendu parce que ça va être la 6e
demain en milieu de match bon car scène
n'a pas réussi à marquer bon c'est le
tenant du titre on s'attend quand même à
ce qu'il conserve son titre mais rien
qui ne démontre le jusqu'à présent très
haut niveau de jeu
il n'est pas vraiment inquiété m'ont
même si carcelle a eu on l'a vu quand
même un deux parties où il avait quand
même un avantage il n'a pas n'a pas
réussi à passer car akin a très bien
défendu mais il était quand même un peu
un peu en retrait là je trouve que la
chine a annulé facilement donc ses
tentatives de car scène de varier ici
n'a pas donné de fruits
ça sera intéressant de voir ce qu'il va
faire et les bains la prochaine mais on
va aussi mis sur voir ce que va faire
car yakine qui a fait quand même de
belles parties aussi avec les blancs et
on va voir ce qu'il va proposer de
nouveau pour la suite voilà super de
super matches toujours belle partie
encore une fois merci de m'avoir suivi
sur des modèles tv pour ce championnat
du monde 2016 et rendez vous donc pour
la pour la prochaine
au revoir